although thirteen point four million  documents have been scrutinized in the  paradise papers leaked the European  Parliament is asking EU countries to  strengthen the fight against tax evasion  for the first time worldwide EU trade  rules will require partners outside the  EU to meet international social and  environmental standards to prevent  dumping 37 percent of online shops and  booking websites didn't respect you  rules in 2014 new rules were approved in  order to better protect consumers Sami  blood is the winner of the 2017 lux film  prize for the best of European cinema  the film sheds a light on the  discriminated Sami people and will be  subtitled in the EU 24 official  languages 1.3 million people applied for  asylum inside the EU in 2016 lawmakers  agreed to start negotiations on the  so-called Dublin or forum to ensure a  fair share of asylum seekers between EU  countries